[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ محمد نور اسود في مدينه حلب
السوريه نشا وترعرع في حلقات الذكر ومجالس
القران والعلوم الشرعيه قبل التحاقه بكليه
الشريعه بجامعه دمشق التي تخرج منها اماما
وخطيبا في مساجد حلب الا ان مسار حياته
تغير كليا بعد الاحداث التي عرفتها سوريا
واختطافه من قبل جماعه ارهابيه
بدانا منذ نعومه اظفاري في تعلم القران
الكريم وكان حقيقه لوالده الفضل الاول في
هذا الامر لانه كانت في بعض الاحيان والدي
يعمل ساعات طويله فكانت تسهر وتنتظر والدي
حتى يعود فكانت تقول لي يا ابني اقرا لي
قران
افتح المصحف واقرا فمنذ ذلك الحين قالت
والله تقرا مثل عبد الباسط عبد الصمد ما
شاء الله فكانت تحفزني انا اعلم انه
قراءتي ما كانت كذلك ولكن هي تحفز وكانت
دائما تقول لي اقرا
بنغمه كذا اقرا بكذا اقرا كذا فاقرا لها
فتسرت وكانت عندما تنتظر يعني والدي حتى
يعود من العمل
فلما كانت تقول لي اقرا لي وسمعني بالنغم
فانا اكتشفت انه والله الامر حلو وجميل
فبدات اذهب الى مسجد يعني قريب بيتنا اسمه
جامع الفتح ما زال قائمه للان والشيخ اللي
كان يدرسنا موجود الى الان وهو كبير الان
في السن في السن اسمه الشيخ محمد نديم
الشهابي بدات رحلتي حقيقه في القران من
ذلك المسجد فلما
ذهبت اول مره مع والدي
سجلني عند احد الاساتذه في المسجد اسمه
الاستاذ رضوان زينو كان رجل متواضع وكان
يعني سبحان الله كانه قران يمشي على الارض
وهو الى الان على قيد الحياه الحمد لله
فجلست عنده تقريبا سنتين
اقرا فقط جزء عمه فقط
كلما انتهينا نبدا من جديد كلما انتهينا
نبدا من جديد الى ان قال لي الان تستطيع
ان تنتقل الى حلقه اخرى فالمسجد كان كل
عمود من اعمده المسجد في حلقه وفي استاذ
على الترتيب القديم ترتيب الحلق القديمه
فكنت تدخل الى المسجد حقيقه كانك تسمع
دبيب النحل كله يقرا والمسجد كان السقف
عالي وكبير تسمع كله يقرا القران سبحان
الله صوت رائع جدا هذا الصوت الناعم وهذا
الصوت خشن وهذا صوت عالي وهذا صوته منخفض
يعني شيء حقيقه عندما يدخل الانسان يحس
يشعر بانه مخدر سبحان الله
فانتقلت الى حلقه
يعني اعلى قليلا سمع مني الاستاذ مره
مرتين ثلاث قال انت مكانك ليس هنا اذهب
الى الحلقه تلك ودلني الى اعلى حلقه في
المسجد
فلما ذهبت وكانوا رجالا انا كنت يعني
تقريبا يمكن عمري عشره او احد عشر سنه فقط
فجلست مع رجال كبار انا اقرا بصوت ناعم
وهم يقراون بصوتهم الخشن فلما دخل الشيخ
الامام الشيخ نديم الى المسجد نظر اليه
قال ماذا تفعل هنا قلت والله يا سيدي
الاستاذ قال لي اجلس هنا قال لا سمعني
فقرات له قال خليك تمام
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
ان الله اصطفى
ادم
ونوحا وال ابراهيم
وال عمران على العالمين
ذريه
بعضها
من بعض والله سميع عليم
[موسيقى]
اذ قالت امراه عمران ربي اني نذرت لك ما
في بطني محررا
ما في بطني محررا
فتقبل
مني
انك
انت السميع العليم
[موسيقى]
فلما وضعتها قالت ربي
اني وضعتها
انثى
والله اعلم بما وضعت
وليس الذكر
كالانثى
واني
سميتها مريم واني
[موسيقى]
اعيذها بك
وذريتها من الشيطان الرجيم
[موسيقى]
فتقبلها ربها بقبول حسن
وانبتها نباتا حسنا
وكف لها زكريا
كلما دخل عليها
زكريا المحراب وجد عندها رزقا
قال يا مريم
انا لك هذا
قالت هو من عند
الله
ان الله يرزق من
يشاء بغير حساب
هنالك دعا زكريا ربه قال رب هب لي من لدنك
ذريه
طيبه
انك سميع الد
صدق الله العظيم
لما بدات الاحداث في سوريا طبعا حلب تاخرت
قليلا عن مجريات الاحداث فكانت الحياه شبه
طبيعيه في في مدينه حلب خاصه
وكانت الامور يعني نوعا ما جيده الى ان
سبحان الله يعني
شملتنا
الموجه
وسبحان الله كان
الدمار كبير في حلب
وانا في المسجد الذي كنت اخطب في الجمعه
كان في وسط هذه الاماكن التي تاثرت كثيرا
في الحرب
فطلب مني
ان اتبع فئه معينه
او منهج معين غير مناسب مع المنهج الذي
تربيت عليه الذي هو منهج السلم والسلام
والمحبه للجميع والتاخي مع الجميع وسماع
الاخر والكلام مع الاخر والاستماع من
الاخر
فسبحان الله
بعض الفئات ما اعجبهم هذا التوجه يعني
دائما عندما تكون انت في الوسط لا يحبك
لاليمين ولا اليسار الجميع يريدونك ان
تكون معهم
فتمت عمليه الخطف بهذه الحجه انك لست معنا
فانت ضدنا تلقائيا بعد صلاه الجمعه انهيت
صلاه الجمعه في المسجد خرجت الى في
السياره عائد الى بيتي سبحان الله
من اليمين واليسار اوقفوا السياره اناس
شباب لا اعرفهم
بالسلاح انزلوني من السياره اخذوا السياره
وضعوني انا معهم في سياره كبيره على ما
اذكر وبعد ذلك وضعوا جلسوا فوقي يعني
وضعوا السلاحهم في حجري وجلسوا فوقي كي لا
يراهم احد لا يراني احد حتى دخلنا الى
خرجنا من لاني مشينا تقريبا نصف ساعه من
مكان
المسجد الذي اخطب فيه الجمعه وبعد ذلك
قالوا لي انت الان
مخطوف
كان المكان الذي انا فيه تحت الارض يعني
يرج من كثر التفجيرات والمعارك انا اسمع
الاصوات سبحان الله والمكان الذي كنت فيه
كان معتما اعتاما يعني كامل لا ارى فيه
حتى يدي
كنت اعرف اصوات
الصلوات اوقات الصلوات في مسجد كان قريب
من المكان عندما اسمع الصلاه خير من النوم
فهون اعرف انه هاي صلاه الفجر
وكان برد شديد سبحان الله ولكن عوده الى
القران الكريم هنا سبحان الله
الذكر ذكر الله
والقران
والنشيد وتذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى والصلاه
على النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام كانت معي
طول هذه الفتره هذه العشره ايام كانت
مؤنثه لي في وحدتي
مولاي
صلي وسلم
دائما
ابدا على
حبيبيك خير الخلق
كلهم
امنت
تذاكر
جيران باذي
سلامي ما
زجتادا عن جرى من مقلاه
بدامه نعم
سرى طيفا اهوى
الرقان
والحب
يا تريض
الذلاتين
الام
مولاي
صلي وسلم
دائما
ابدا على
[تصفيق]
حبيبك خير الخلق
كلهم
وليا ضيق رسول الله
جاهوك
وليا
يضيق رسول الله
اذا الكريم
متجلى باسم
[موسيقى]
منتقيم مولاي
صلي وسلم
دائما
ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق كلهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لجا القارئ محمد نور اسود مع اسرته الى
جنوب افريقيا حيث يعمل بالتدريس كما اسس
مدرسه لتحفيظ القران الكريم للناشئه فيما
يحرص على تحفيظ اولاده القران الكريم وهو
ما تجلى في نبوغ بناته الحافظات وهن في سن
المبكره
وصلت الى جنوب افريقيا في الثاني والعشرين
من ماي 2013
الى مطار جوهانس بعد ذلك الى مطار كيب
تاون فكانت اول مدينه لي للوصول للسكن
كانت في مدينه كيب تاون الذين دعوني اتيت
انا فيزا زياره وبعد ذلك يسر الله عز وجل
ان تكون فيزا عمل وبعد اقامه دائمه الحمد
لله
كنت اماما في كيب تاون في مسجد صغير
بجوار المكان الذي اقيم فيه وبقيت هناك
سته اشهر
وهناك حقيقه اكتشفت يعني انا ما كنت انشد
عاده في في حلب كثيرا لانه تعرف حلب هي ام
الطرب والفن
فواحد مثلي يعني هذا المستوى العالي
للاناشيد والنغم والطرب الحلبي الاصيل
يعني انا كنت استمع واحب فسبحان الله كان
في حفل في كيب تاون كنت جديد يعني اول اول
يومين كان في حفل كان كبير في مسجد اسمه
مس القدس
فاحد الاخوه اخذني الى ذلك الحفل كانسان
عادي جالس انا واستمع
فالذي يريد ان ينشد تاخر في القدوم فقالوا
لي انه يعني انت طالما هون عندهم امر
طالما انك عربي فيجب ان تعرف كيف تنشد
يعني ما في مجال يجب ان تعرف القراءات
وتعرف الاناشيد وكل شيء
فقالوا لي ممكن تنشد فانا كنت انشد في بعض
الزوايا في في حلب وعندي فكره عن الانشاد
والانغام فكره فقط هوايه يعني فوالله بدات
بسم الله انشدت فيعني الحقيقه انا اعجبت
يعني انا قلت والله هذا شيء جميل الحمد
لله
والناس الحاضرين كلهم يعني فرحوا في هذا
النشيد بدات كل شخص عنده مثلا برنامج عنده
حفله عنده اذهب معه الى بيته او الى
الصاله او كذا انشد بعض الاناشيد البسيطه
التي يعني غالبا تكون مما يعرفونها طلع
البدر علينا قمر
طالما اشكو غرامي هذه الاناشيد التي
حسبي ربي جل الله يعرفونها
فمره كنت بعد في البيت طرق على الباب طارق
منشد هو من جنوب افريقيا قال اريد ان
اتعلم منك قلت يا اخي والله انا يعني امام
وخطيب فتريد ان تتعلم النشيد تذهب الى
المنشدين قال لا انت عندك الصوت فنتعلم
سويه قلت نتعلم سويه بسم الله فهنا كان
عندي شبه فرقه بدانا في
تاون للنشيد والى الان ما زالهم مستمرين
انتقلت بعدها الى مدينه ديرما
جلست في ديرمن بعد ذلك طبعا اتت اسرتي
واستقرينا وكل الامور كانت تمام الحمد لله
بعد انتقلت الى مدينه ديربن مدينه دربن
مدينه كبيره جدا وفيها الجاليه الهنديه
ايضا المسلمه كبيره جدا وهي مكان يعني
متنوع وجميل جدا سبحان الله ولكن شاء الله
سبحانه وتعالى بعد سته اشهر بالضبط ان اتي
الى هنا الى بريتوريا وانا اتنقل مع نفس
الاشخاص يعني هم لما كنا في كيب تاون هم
طلبوا مني ان اذهب الى ديربن ممكن تذهب
هناك ايضا من يريد ان يتعلم
فذهبت الى دولمان واسست يعني كمان ايضا
فرقه صغيره والى الان هم مستمرين في الحلق
الذكر والنشيد ويعني الاذكار
وبعد ذلك اتينا الى هنا وفي هذا المسجد
هنا بالضبط بدانا رحله التعليم
للقران في المدرسه المجاوره
وحلق الذكر والدروس والاناشيد واللغه
العربيه ايضا كان عندي ايضا هنا يعني
تقريبا اربعين خمسين طالب كانوا يتعلمون
اللغه العربيه بقيت على ذلك مده خمس سنوات
تقريبا وبعد ذلك وفقني الله عز وجل انه
اسست لنفسي مركزا اسلاميا صغيرا يعتني
خاصه بالاطفال من سن خمس سنوات الى سن
تقريبا ثلاثه عشر سنه 14 سنه بالتجويد
والقواعد الاساسيه للقران الكريم وكذا
والحمد لله ان الله عز وجل يعني
يسر لي ان احمل هذه الرساله رساله الصوت
الجميل مع القران والنشيد والدروس العلميه
من سوريا من حلب الى جنوب افريقيا هنا
وخاصه في بريتوريا هنا حتى ان الصحيفه
المحليه هنا اختاروني
كالشخصيه الثانيه المؤثره في الشباب
طالما اشكو غرامي يا نور الوجود
[موسيقى]
وانادياتها يا معدن
الجود
[موسيقى]
الجوع اللهم
الله الله الله
[موسيقى]
منيتي اقصى ما رمي
احظى بالش
وهوف
منيتي اقصى مرامي احظى
بالشهور
وارى باب السلام يا سامي الجود
[موسيقى]
وارى باب السلام
يا سامي الجود
ود جنوب افريقيا بشكل عام هي فريده من
نوعها بالتنوع الثقافي ما بين حتى في
السكان الاصليين هم تقريبا اكثر من خمسه
عشر ثقافه مختلفه
عدا الهنود
الاجانب الذين اتوا مثلا من 200 او 100
سنه هم ايضا متنوعون وعندك الماليزيين
وعندك الاندونيسيين وعندك الملونين يعني
هي بيئه متنوعه جدا فالاسلام الموجود في
جنوب افريقيا طبعا الاسلام واحد ولكن
سبحان الله الاسلام الموجود في جنوب
افريقيا متنوع ايضا
يعني ترى جميع مشارب الكره الارضيه جميع
الاسلام بجميع مذاهبه سواء كانوا على حق
او على غير حق تراهم موجودين في جنوب
افريقيا ولكن الميزه
الجميله والرائعه في جنوب افريقيا هنا
وخاصه انا يعني اتكلم عن محيطي التفاهم
انا لمذهبي ولك مذهبك وكلنا نعبد ربا
واحدا في علاقات اسريه قويه في علاقات
تجاريه قويه بين الناس
فالاختلاف في المذاهب اعطاهم ثراء فكريا
فاحيانا تجلس مع شاب عمره 20 او 25 سنه
عنده ثقافه اسلاميه متنوعه متفهم يفهم
ويسمع ويتاثر طيب القلب كرماء محبين للنبي
عليه الصلاه والسلام جدا
عاطفتهم للاسلام عاطفه قويه جدا جدا جدا
ومحبون للسلام يحبون السلام بشكل كبير
يحبون الحياه الهادئه وهم اصحاب يعني
خدمه ايضا فالان انا حسب ما اعرف ان هناك
كثير من الجمعيات الاسلاميه
ترعى فقراء من جميع انحاء العالم هي بدات
من جنوب افريقيا فلذلك
التنوع اذا لم يكن معه تفاهم واستيعاب
للاخر فيكون التنوع مشكله ولكن هنا في
جنوب افريقيا في تنوع مع تفاهم
ومحبه
وفي مدارس اسلاميه كثير
وافضل واجمل برامج وحفلات يقومون بها ليست
حفلات عيد الميلاد او حفلات
انما هي حفلات حفظ القران لا يحفظ الطالب
القران الا تقوم المدرسه يقومون بعمل حفل
له ويحضرون الضيافه ويحضرون المنشدين
ويفرحون بمناسبه انه فلان انهى حفظ القران
الكريم
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
الم
ذلك الكتاب لا ريب فيه
هدى للمتقين
الذين يؤمنون بالغيب ويقيمون الصلاه
ومما رزقناهم
ينفقون
[موسيقى]
والذين يؤمنون
بما
انزل اليك
وما
لمن قبلك
وبالاخره هم يوقنون
اولئك على هدى
واولئك هم المفلحون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات